foreign
where are you from originally Reno
Nevada Reno and tell me about your
family
um yep Mom and Dad married
um High School sweethearts uh I have two
sisters
um I was the oldest
my mom was an RN my dad was a doctor
they both passed away
doctor in your childhood but later in
life
um I grew up I was normal I went to
Catholic School
um we lived in a middle-class
neighborhood my dad had a small practice
um
I was I did great I think and then I was
a swimmer
um
at 15 I ended up pregnant with my
friends older brother's child my parents
had me get married at 15 and I delivered
my first child at the day after my 16th
birthday
yeah and did you marry
I was married yeah to Peter
um we decided we had another child a
year later
so I was 17 with two children under the
age of two
and it wasn't going well
with my husband
um he was a lot older than I was there
was a lot of domestic violence
um my parents bailing me out all the
time
uh
and I met Jacob
when I was 19 years old
uh
he was 24 and he had tattoos all over
and he was at the Sparks Marina and I
fell in love with him and I asked him
you know
what are you fresh out of prison you
know I'd never met anybody who'd gone to
prison or anything like that and he said
yeah two weeks
and um
we started dating my parents actually
adored him took him in went to church I
was a Sunday school teacher
my kids were doing great
um
and we decided to have a baby
and we got pregnant pretty quickly and I
found out that he was using
math some things had turned out missing
at our house I didn't really know what
that was I lived in extremely sheltered
life
um you know no television
even though I had children my parents
were a big part of raising them so I
could finish school
and um
we were at the doctor when I was nine
months pregnant
and uh he sucked he punched my doctor Dr
Paz because he touched me
well I didn't have my clothes on my OB
GYN
and uh
I you know I said you know you've got to
get off this drug I didn't know what it
was and um
he
said he would and he went to go to sleep
but at a friend's house
and uh
the next thing I know
I'm watching the news and he's been
tasered by the police
the Sparks Police Department
and um he was dead I was nine months
pregnant
he died on June 9th 2004. from
um well they say that it was a massive
heart attack
um he he was asleep
the police came and woke him up um due
to the woman he was staying with
he opened the door and let the police in
and um
he had committed some property crime I
don't know who had gone in there it was
the first year that tasers had been
introduced into the police force and uh
they tasered him when he woke up
combative and
um he died there they say he died at the
hospital but he died there and um
I was on June 9th 2004 and our son was
born on June 21st
2004.
you're supposed to be a little girl but
he turned out to be a boy
and is there any supplement in that suit
I can't talk about that unfortunately
okay
um where'd your life go from there
uh
well
that was the same week that my mom had
been diagnosed with stage four colon
cancer at 50.
and so she was in the hospital when I
was delivering
she had had her intestines removed my
dad was in Hong Kong
um he was the director of the YMCA there
and um
it just was crazy I was the mom of three
kids I was doing it by myself pretty
much I was in college
my two oldest went to their dad every
other week
and I had my youngest and
every
my parents moved to California to San
Ramon Danville area
for treatment for my mom's cancer
we didn't have health insurance because
we didn't need it you know they handled
it themselves and so pretty much
everything that they had was sold
to take care of my mom
and uh every Friday night I was working
at the pepper mill at the time and going
to school
I would leave work pick up my kids pick
up my sisters and we would drive to
California where I'd relieve my dad
um to help take care of my mom who was
on hospice and
um I'd come home every
Sunday night and go back to work and do
it all again and we did that for a year
and I got a phone call Monday morning
one morning that she had passed
and so it was kind of just
dealing with that I didn't really think
about everything that had happened with
Jacob it was
just I was doing what I had to do
because our matriarch was
dying and um
she passed away and our family just
came unglued I came unglued I didn't
know what to do with myself I was Idle
Hands I was so busy all of a sudden I
had nothing
um I
never really told anybody this but
I asked my husband my ex-husband
the kid the kid's dad
if um
kids don't even know this
if he would please just take the kids
for a little while because I needed to
deal with my mom's affairs
and I never went back for them for the
two oldest
I just fell off face of the earth I took
the baby and I left
not because of drugs or anything I
wasn't doing drugs then
I was drinking pretty heavily but I met
my now husband
a man who was going to help me raise my
baby
father they had a dad so my two oldest
just left them in Reno and I never went
back and I married well I didn't marry
him right away but
I uh
dated him and he raised Gabriel my
youngest
as his own
and uh
we lived in a house in Benicia
California it's beautiful
I had a perfect family I kind of just
almost killed my two oldest kids in my
head because I didn't ever tell
my husband about them
um
or my son
and I just never spoke to them and um
I lived my life completely normal I was
a soccer mom
I was out of PTO
I was doing everything I was supposed to
do and my youngest had a beautiful life
and um
adopted my husband's family the same way
I did they adopted us I didn't have
anybody
and then 2013
I got a phone call
that my dad was at Mesa General
um
he'd been found
unresponsive
and he was brain dead
from an overdose
and uh
me being the oldest I needed to come to
Mesa because I was medical power of
attorney
and my sisters were in Guam at the time
well one sister was in Guam the other
was in Vegas
and
I made the decision to take him off life
support and donate his organs
which is what he wanted and Mesa law
um I was drinking then I mean drinking
I've been drinking ever since my mom
died
and uh
it was up to about a gallon of vodka a
day and I was like walking blood alcohol
level was 0.23 not slurring stumbling
anything I was I mean I was drinking
every day just to get up I had to wake
up to drink so I wouldn't have seizures
and my marriage was falling apart
Taylor had recently contacted me and
said she ran away from home I hadn't
spoken to her and
God 10 years
and uh
I wouldn't take her phone call because I
was afraid my husband would find out it
was all just a lie like the whole time I
just been living this incredible lie
all because of just one tiny thing and I
feel sick I was so sick to my stomach
all the time and worried about every
phone call that was going to come
and uh so I decided to leave my husband
which is what I do best I run away when
something isn't going my way
um
my youngest still didn't know about his
siblings
and
I had lied and I moved back to Reno
I just left him he didn't tell him
anything I took half of everything and
left and he just didn't know I don't
know how he found out I think his mom
told him because I told his mom
and we hadn't spoken since
but that was in like 2016 that was three
years later I mean three years of just
living like
drinking not knowing when he was gonna
find out and I mean we were married for
13 years or together for 13 years
and I came back to Reno
which way I thought was home because
my home had been phenicia but everyone
was gone from Reno
and um
I thought I'd finally I started saying
like oh I have three kids you know not
just one I have three
and I thought it was just going to be
some easy transition into being their
mother again
but I mean they were grown
and they wanted nothing to do with me
and my sisters they were so angry at me
they had told my son my youngest
but I lied his whole life to him that he
had an older brother and sister
that he lived with for two years of his
life
and uh
he decided he didn't want to live with
me anymore either
so he left
and uh
they pretty much just stopped talking to
me
all together
none of them my sisters and that's the
only family we have
we don't have anybody else everyone
passed away
and
I was just left and we know by myself
and it didn't feel like home
and I met somebody
a girl
and all these people were doing drugs
around me
I thought [ __ ] let's do it
until I was 36.
and I started
using meth intravenously
first time
and I've been using every day since then
and my life is slowly
foreign
I don't fit in anywhere
I don't fit in with my old friends
I don't fit in with
the people here
everybody thinks I'm a prostitute
no one really knows what to think
because no one trusts me
so I've just been going from place to
place looking for whatever
so you've just been traveling around for
how long now
um
um I guess the year
I take the train I had cars
I had a place in Reno for a long time
um through covid and all that
uh which is where I got my friends or
acquaintances that I have now
I don't think there's a person on this
Earth that actually knows what I just
told you everything there's gonna be a
lot of surprise people
go eat my children
I
I pretended
like I did when Taylor and Lucas were
gone
I just
blocked it out and
created a new life for myself
and was happy in it because it's the
only way to survive
I was Sarah the drug addict now
and
but I
have had so many faces
or masks or whatever you want to call it
and they played it so well every time
I don't even know who I am anymore
or if I ever nope
what do you think is behind this
tendency to
kind of just
file away parts of your life
no even your kids
probably everyone says that oh Sarah you
have an excuse or at least you know like
people who knew me oh it makes total
sense you know you lost your mom you
lost Jacob you were a single mom
postpartum depression I mean I have all
of these excuses but I've never said
them
because I don't want Taylor Lucas to
ever think that there's a reason
that made it okay what I did
because nothing is ever going to make
that okay
but
I've never said it you know hey by the
way you know your dad hey he's almost
30. you know when he was 15.
or maybe he
you know
I've never said
well you know I did it because my mom
died or because of this I don't know if
there is a reason
I just know that it happened
and I can't make up for it
but it's killing me
literally
I don't like anything like I used to
but
I guess that comes with four years of
I can't even
I'm a bad drug addict even I can't even
do drugs anymore I'm so bad at it I try
and I can't my veins are shot out
all right
only half the people that I know right
now even know that I use drugs
the ones who use with me
but no one's ever stayed long enough to
oh
or maybe I don't stay long enough
to get close anymore is it an
unwillingness to take response
responsibility for oh no I take 100
responsibility for everything now would
you walk away from your kids and just
pretend they don't exist
to take responsibility for that well I
mean like you you have two children you
just kind of
I left them with their dad yeah
um
I do take no I know I can I don't know
why I did it
I wanted
I didn't it wasn't no it wasn't that I
wanted Gabriel to have a good life I
don't know and I felt like they could do
that there there is no excuse it wasn't
because I was sick or anything like that
it was because I made a conscious
decision to leave them there I knew what
I was doing you were drug-free when you
made that decision yes and that's the
saddest part
I wish I had anything drugs in front of
the picture it would have made sense
yeah I was an alcoholic but not like
to the point of
I knew what I was doing and I'm sorry
that's all I can say
I didn't make the right decision or
maybe I did [ __ ] I don't know
because they were all amazing
now they're doing great how old are your
kids now
my daughter is 23. nice and she's in the
Navy she's very smart
uh award-winning
um my son some Marines
he's doing great he's 21. she's turned
21.
and my youngest turned 18. this last
week
did you talk to him and he's in the Army
going in the Army okay yeah all military
all military do you talk with any of
them
talk to the oldest
she writes me on Facebook
but that's it we um got in contact
two years ago
I wrote her
I asked her if she wanted to know my
story
it was the first time I was ever going
to tell it but she didn't want to
but she said she'd start a relationship
with me
but she would never give me her phone
number or address
I've tried I've asked I was going to see
her a couple weeks ago
but I came back this way from the East
Coast
for a guy
which is more important apparently
so
now
it's been probably the worst it's ever
been
I have no real
source of income
uh
I
been put in some pretty hairy situations
that I put myself in
because
I don't have anywhere to go
I don't have any friends anymore to call
on to ask for money or a place to stay
I've burned those bridges not in a bad
way but in the kind of way that I'm not
I'm too embarrassed anymore
um
three weeks ago I was in Bakersfield
underneath the bridge
and now I'm here on Skid Row
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
I don't know
I can't think of it
again think of a time I can't think of a
moment where something happened where it
went bad
I don't know when that happened or when
I decided to choose
all right
make bad decisions like continuously
make them
and I know I'm making them so I guess
that's the hardest part
is maybe do you think you're still
making decisions that are oh absolutely
did you do this before you
the parts of your story that were like
those were all conscious bad decisions
that were you like in your teen years
and even before you were when I was
about I think I started when I was about
15.
yeah it was
Middle School of uh private school it
was private school and I I wanted to
hang out with the
kids that were across the street not at
my Catholic school I wanted to go to
Clayton Middle School
and be what those kids were
and I didn't want to be what we were
doing I wasn't interested in any of that
you know I was smart and
in a situation where I could make
something of myself I did make something
of myself I just was never happy doing
it
I was doing it for my parents I was
scared to death of Authority and I still
am I'm scared of everything I have no
idea how I do this every day
you know I
crawl right
I'm scared to death
all the time what are you most afraid of
um
dying alone
I don't think that anyone would even
notice if I was gone
they never do
if I change my phone number or something
my phone doesn't ever ring I turned it
off when we came in here like someone
was going to call me
no one does
it's weird because I get a lot of
attention
all the time a lot
but there's not one person that would
come and find me if it was the end of
the world
I wouldn't be anybody's person
so I'm lonely
not like as you know in a partner or
anything just yeah friends I'm isolated
[Music]
but it's me who does it
you get depressed from all this oh God
it's an understatement I have such
anxiety it's insane
I if I could cry all of the time I
probably would but if I did I don't have
anywhere to do it I mean
I've gotten my own place now actually
um I got set up but yeah instead of
doing what I'm supposed to be doing I'm
still here shocked up with somebody
is that the drug making you make bad
decisions now or is it still the same I
don't know no because I should tell you
the truth I can't even get high
I don't even I rarely get high anymore
that's the thing I really can't
I can't do it and I refuse to smoke it
so
I'm pretty much sober making terrible
decisions no it's it's the drugs I don't
know what it is honestly
I have no idea
maybe you know all the I don't know I
don't know
I I can't pinpoint anything it might be
some kind of it's a metal yeah no yeah
I'm sure it is I've never been diagnosed
but
I'm sure I am I was on Prozac for like
postpartum depression but
it's kind of like like the way a gambler
will do something that just doesn't make
sense yeah and do it anyway and they
know better that's kind of like what
you're doing over and over and over
again and then you know what unless
anything unless it's handed to me
like just here you go Sarah on a silver
platter
because it's not that I don't try I will
work hard at whatever I do and I will do
the best I mean I'm the best at
everything that I do
but I don't think that any of those
things are really me I think I'm
I'm a pretty I play Parts really well
and I don't know why that is
I've never actually been Sarah and I
don't know who she is either so
I'm very disassociated for myself is it
do you think there's something what do
you think you're looking for by doing
these things that's the thing I don't
have any goal not one I honestly could
care less if I die tomorrow
I have nothing to look forward to
that's how sad it is
I'm not capable of taking my own life or
anything like that but
it wouldn't make any difference to me
there's not
if I could maybe have my kids in my life
that would be the only thing
and for
I don't know
pretend I don't know I live in a fairy
tale
I do and that's how I get through life
every day
is with drugs and my make-believe
stories
that everything's okay and none of these
bad things ever happen
half the people I know don't even know
about my mom or my dad or Jacob or
my family
I pretend like I just perfect
I don't need everyone's sympathy
because it's in my mind it didn't even
happen
it looks like your typical
Skid Row drug user
yeah I know that's why I don't fit in no
one likes me here you don't seem to fit
in here
no there was a girl throwing rocks at me
the other day
walking down the street in the middle of
the night
um tallest woman I'd ever seen just
scared the crap out of me she had no
pants on
I looked at that
and the time
and the fact that I was holding mace in
my hand I had needles in my bag
a police officer drove by me completely
unaware of me
and I was like wow when did this happen
like how is this even possible this is
the kind of thing that I saw on the
television
on these movies that we watched
this isn't a real place for a real place
that I could be I know it's a place I
thought it was like a just a saying I
didn't even know and
I thought how is this your life
like how you go from
that to this
and it wasn't even mad like I'm okay
with it like there's not
because that's what you're doing and you
better do a good job at it
but it's more like now
when I I used to be like the center of
attention or just you know I demanded
you know
everybody you know
pay attention to me and be the center of
attention from the room just demand it
and now I I remember the first time that
I really truly had no place to go like I
had my dog
and it was snowing and then Reno
and I was like what do I do so I walked
to my childhood home
and I thought I'm just going to go there
and see how I feel and that was when it
started my whole my actual my whole trip
I walked there
with my dog in his stroller because he
was blind and it was like well that's
not my house it hasn't been my house in
16 years okay so that's not it and I was
like there's nowhere in Reno that I feel
close to anybody
so what do I do this is where I came
and my mom told me what she said go to
church
go find a Methodist Church and tell them
you're a member
that you were confirmed here just find
one if you're ever in trouble
a long time ago she said I said okay
so I went to my church that I had gone
to for years
taught Sunday school the children that I
taught
we're all older
people who are still there that knew my
mom and dad I sat on the stairs
there was no
and it wasn't that nobody would help it
was that nobody even saw me
it wasn't Sarah anymore
I wasn't the person that they knew I was
just that homeless person sitting on
their strict steps these are people I
knew
nobody sees you when you're like this
you're not a person you're nothing
you're a statistic
and it makes me sad
and I wish that there was something that
I could do but because I used to but I
can't
so
I am not any different
than anybody out here
I'm just as homeless I'm just as much of
a drug addict just as much as a screw-up
or
mentally ill as every single one of them
if not more
so it sucks to not fit in on either side
Sarah thank you so much for sharing your
story thank you